رياضة السيارات ليست رياضة مجال نسائي
و لو تشوف العالم كله
طلع لي بطلة عالم أنثى
ما فيه
لأنه كل اللي استخدمهم الإعلام، استخدمهم بعدين رماهم
وكثير لو تتفرج
طلعه الإعلام
ومقابلات جرائد ورعاة
أخذوا حاجتهم منها اللي هي البروز، ثم..
ما تلقاها، ما عاد تلقاها
المتسابق سعيد الموري
متسابق رياضة سيارات
ما أبغى أقول أبطال المملكة، أحد شباب المملكة
اللي إن شاء الله يمثلها خير تمثيل
متسابق رسميًا في عام 2006
19, 17, 18..
17 سنة
سقت وأنا صغير وتعلمت السيارات وحبيتها
إلى اليوم هذا من عام..
الحين يمكن 20 سنة
وأنا كلها تخصصي فقط سيارات
رياضة السيارات، سباقات والتدريب
«هل كنت مفحطًا سابقًا؟»
أي حد في جيلي، اللي هو جيل الـ 2000
أو مواليد الثمانينات
بس الجيل اللي عاصرنا آخر التسعينات والألفين
ما كان عندنا شيء نسويه في السعودية أو في الرياض
كنا نفرغ طاقتنا في التفحيط
كانت هي مبدأ إثبات، إثبات وجود
فالكل يبغى يتعلم التفحيط
يبغي يثبت مرجلته
أول شيء، كل شيء بقضاء الله وقدره
ولكن لا يمكن أن تعتقد..
أو أنا أقولها كذا بالعامية
كذاب اللي يقول أنا متحكم في السيارة
هذا غير صادق
أبرز المفحطين في الفترات التي فاتت معروفين
ناس معروفة
ولكن فيه كثير فوق ما تتخيل ناس تفحط بس مالها ألقاب
ناس بس كذا، تبغى تأخذ سيارة وتطلع وتجرب
بس.. وتوزِّن
وبس.. فأنا كنت من الصف الثاني
أو حتى الصف الثالث
فكانت الناس أول سبب الشهرة
ثاني سبب تفريغ الطاقة
ثالث سبب الأدرينالين.. هذا في السباقات الآن
« هل تعدّ سباقات السيارات رياضة؟»
بالعكس، رياضة السيارات رياضة متعبة بشكل كبير
الناس تعتقد جالس في سيارة وتسوق.. أبدًا
متعبة، يعني فيها مجهود
مجهود كبير على الجسم
أيضًا فيه سباقات شاركنا فيها
سباقات تحمل أربع وعشرين ساعة
سباق أربع وعشرين ساعة متواصلة وأنت تسوق
وتبدل مع سائقين
معاك زملاء في الفريق
يدك تتحرك طوال الوقت
عينك ورأسك تتحرك طوال الوقت
أقدامك تتحرك بين فرامل البنزين والكلتش طوال الوقت
يعني طوال الوقت وأنت شغَّال
حتى شرب الماء في السباقات
في أماكن معينة نقدر نشرب فيها الماء
مع أن اللي موجود في فمك
بس من كثر ما أنت مشغول بين فرامل والقير
أحيانًا ما يمديك تشرب ماء
فهي رياضة متعبة بشكل كبير ترى
اليوم في سباقات (Kart racing) «الكارتينق»
فيه مشاريع كثير تدفع 50-100 ريال وتسوق كارتينق
عشرة دقائق بس
ألعبها وبعدين بتجاوب على نفسك على السؤال
كارتينق صغيرة سيارة
يعني أصغر من طاولة طعام
تسوقها وسرعتها ما توصل ستين
تنزل من عشرة دقائق وأنت منهك
معرق وتعبان، ففيها جهد كبير مرة
«أصعب سباق مر عليك؟»
كان فيه رالي لبنان
رالي لبنان رالي خطر وصعب
طرق جبلية كله زي أبها والجنوب
بين بيوت فوق الجبل كله
فأنا كنت أمشي يمكن 150-160
في منعطف صغير كذا وراء بيت
الرالي ينطلقون سيارة وراء سيارة
كل دقيقتين سيارة
فكان قدامي المنطلقين وأنا كنت وراء
ففيه حجارة على الطريق
وفيه منعطف ضيق جدًا
أنا جاي ممكن أمشي 150-160
بس بعشِّق رابع، بهدأ شوي
يعني على 120-120 وألف
ساعة دخلت اللفة إلا فيه حجر مرمي في الطريق
فضربتها
فيه وادي صغير تحت، طرت وطحت فيه جوَّا
السيارة ما جاها شيء كثير
ولكن من قوة الضربة الوقوف..
ليه؟ لأن من سرعة 130 وقفت فجأة
هذي اللي ضرتني
لو متقلب كان ما حسيت بشيء
صار عندي شرخ في الحوض وإنزلاق
والملاح انكسر ظهره بس الحمدلله سهالات
«هل سباقات السيارات آمنة؟»
لا أبدًا الحمدلله
بالعكس الخطورة ما هي عالية زي ما تعتقد الناس
تعتقد إحنا اليوم..
رياضة السيارات كل مالها تضافي إليها عوامل سلامة أكثر
اليوم إحنا فيه أشياء نجربها
بعد خمس سنين تلقاها عندك
فيه أشياء إحنا جربناها من ثلاث أو أربع سنين
سواءً في الإطارات
جربناها أو في قطع في السيارة
اليوم هي موجودة في سيارتك
عوامل الأمان عوامل السلامة
قطع تتحمل مسافات طويلة فهي مختبر متنقل
بالعكس أنت لو تقول لي أركب خيل وأركض على شيء
أو سيارة
بقول لك بركب السيارة، أنا الخيل ممكن أطيح
و ينكسر ظهري أو يصير لي شيء
بس في السيارة أنا محاط بعوامل السلامة
فإن شاء الله أنه أقل خطورة من الخيل
أنت صادق؟
أيه متأكد واسأل أي أحد
«أغرب حادثة سباق حصلت لك؟»
في رالي داكار
كنت وراء جيب و مسرعين فما أشوف
و كان مطر في ذيك الأيام
كانت المرحلة في وادي الدواسر
فأنا وراه وطايرين
أنا ما أبغاه يروح عني لأنه ما يقدر يمين ولا يسار
الباب لازم أمشي معه في نفس المسار
لأنه فيه قشوع وإذا طلعت عن المسار يمكن أقلب
فقلت خلاص ركز، وقاعد أطالع في..
أتذكر والله أني قمت أطالع في النسافات حق الجيب بس
وأنزل عيني وأشوف لونها أزرق
والله أني أذكرها إلى الحين
قاعد أقول ايوه أشوف النسافات
وشوي اختفى كل شيء وصرت أشوف ماء
أثره وصل عند البركة
ولف يمين أنا ما عاد أمداني
فطبيت
والحمدلله قاعد داعس وطلعت مع الجهة الثانية
ولكني شربت ممكن لترين ماء من البركة
كلها طحالب
وما أدري أيش دخل في بطني وقتها
أتذكر أنه في شيء أخضر يسبح ودخل فمي
بس ما أدري وش هو
رحت المركز الطبي وشرحت لهم وأعطوني محلول
قالوا خذها وإن شاء الله تزين أمورك
وإذا ارتفعت حراراتك تعال وإذا ما ارتفعت إن شاء الله عادي
فالحمدلله ما ارتفعت الحرارة
«ماذا تلبس أثناء السباق؟»
طبعًا إحنا وقت السباق لازم نلبس...
أول شيء ملابس داخلية من تحت إلى فوق
تكرمون. تبدأ من الشراب
هذه مو ضد الحريق ولكنها تعطيك وقت أنها ما تحترق
ولا تلزق في جسمك
فهي واقية
بعدين نلبس فوقها البدلة اللي هي أيضًا مقاومة للحريق فترة اطول
بعدين فوقها القفاز
أيضًا هذه
تكرمون الجزمة، أيضًا مقاومة للحريق إلى حد معين
بعدين نلبس ونغطي الوجه نسميه (Balaklava) أو القناع
وهذا أيضًا
بعدين الخوذة
والخوذة في شيء يسمى (Hans Devices) «جهاز هانز»
اللي هو يربط في الصدر أو على الكتف
تربط فيه الخوذة عشان لا سمح الله..
لو صار حادث قوي، ما تنخنع رقبتك
ويمسك الرقبة
هذا هو. بعد كذا نربط الأحزمة ونتوكل على الله
أيه والله يا ساتر، حر مو طبيعي
ترى توصل الحرارة في الرالي وبعض السباقات
توصل الحرارة جوَّا السيارات إلى خمسين أو ستين
حر مو طبيعي
وتخيل أنك تسوق ساعتين متواصلة
بعدين تبدل اللي بعدك وترجع تسوق ساعتين
يصير منهك
أتذكر مرتين من سباق الأربع وعشرين ساعة هذه ينكسر سني
من كثر ما أنا مركز وأضغط على فمي، انكسر سني
«هل سبق وانقطع عنك البنزين أثناء السباق؟»
أتذكر رالي حائل لما شاركت عام 2009 أو 2010
انقطع علي البنزين وأنا في نص المرحلة
كان في مخيم بعيد يمكن يبعد عني كيلو وسط البر
فبعيد، فأنا قعدت استنى
خلال نص ساعة كذا إلا جاني شايب كبير في السن
وقف عندي، قال سلامات يا ولدي
قلت الله يسلمك، انقطع عني البنزين
قال لي يا رجال أنت اللي مع السباق؟ قلت أيه
قال الرجال روَّحوا
قلت لا طال عمرك إحنا بين كل سيارة وسيارة دقيقتين
فهو لما شاف السيارات راحت قبلي
يعتقد أني خلاص أنا وراء
قال يعني بتلحقهم؟ قلت باقي سيارات وراي بتجي بعد
قال أجل تبغى بنزين؟ قلت أيه
قال والله ما أعطيك بنزين إلى أن تتغدى عندي
قالت يا عم الله يطوِّل عمرك وراي سباق
قال والله ما تذوق البنزين إلى أن تتغدى عندي
أحب رأسه، الله يغنيك. والله برجع لك بعد الرالي
قال أبدًا ما فيه بنزين
أنا وإياه إلى أن قال لو تذوق أي شيء من عندي
شوف الكرم كيف الله يطول في عمره
حلف بعدين قال خلاص أبشر، راح جاب لي بنزين
جاب معه تمر و فاكهة
وقال هذا البنزين، تأكل وخذ البنزين
والله أكلت تمر ثم قال تفضل البنزين
«كيف يكون السباق مصدر دخل؟»
رياضة السيارات مكلفة جدًا، مكلفة فوق ما تتخيل
هو لازم معايير معينة أنه ممكن الناس تدفع لك
أول شيء خبرتك
خبرتك في القيادة
إثنين عدد حوادثك، قلة حوادثك
ثلاثة نتائجك
أربعة مصداقيتك
ففيه أشياء كثيرة تحدد أنك ممكن يندفع لك
أو ممكن ما يندفع لك أنك تسوق
اليوم فيه سباقات بس سيارات غالية أو ثرية أو..
ما تنتج أبطال نهائيًا في نهاية المطاف
من خبرتي في المجال ما يستمرون
أغلب اللي يدخل بالشكل هذا
يدخل بس يأخذ الهالة الإعلامية حوله
وخلاص ما يستمر
يستمر فقط الطموح
واللي حاب يستثمر في نفسه في رياضة السيارات
يقولون لي الناس
أنت ليش تسوق التريلا مع حقتك؟
أقولهم يا اخي أنا مبسوط
باستطاعتي اليوم أجيب سائق يسوقها
وأركب سيارتي وأقول أنا بطل المملكة وأشخِّص
بس فعليًا ما يمشي، انبسط إذا سقت وامسك الخط
أمسك التريلا وأروح، روقان ما بعد الروقان
والله أني أغنى على نفسي بعض الأحيان
يطلع صوت صدى في التريلا،
فأطرب نفسك بنفسك
يطلع صدى لأن التريلا كبيرة، فتحس نفسك ستار أكاديمي
ما أحس نفسي إلا ووصلت
وللا أوقف في محطة وأعبي ديزل
أكل عدس
والله اللي ما جرب العدس في محطة في الخط
هذا ما جرب
يكون أفغاني ولا باكستاني يسويه
بعدين يجيك كاتب هـ و ط بدل النقطتين ولام
وقف، لا تسأل وقف
هذه نجمة ميشلان لمطاعم الخط